telle une blessure béante la place
georges flow et des devenu un lieu sacré
presque de pèlerinage où les gens se
recueille
sa mort a ouvert les yeux de la mairie
dit joe biden sur les injustices
raciales
son image est partout devenue le symbole
de la souffrance des afro-américains
l'intersection est toujours fermé elle
va rouvrir après le procès nous dit on
comme si cela dépend des du verdict le
poing levé ils étaient des centaines
devant le palais de justice où devait se
faire la sélection du jury
la foulée diverses mobilisés en
attendant le procès de chéraga rouault
est devenu le visage la voix des
victimes collatérales la mort de josh
freese a ravivé sa douleur son cauchemar
commence il ya 11 ans lorsque son fiancé
justin tigre est retrouvé mort le 19
août 2009 dite est mon fiancé de père de
mon fils de trois ans a été battu à mort
et jeté dans une benne à ordures elle
n'avait que 23 ans
depuis elle élève seule son fils de 14
ans justin qui porte le même prénom que
son père oui c'est derrière john floyd
dit elle il ya des centaines de meurtres
non élucidés de l'aïe le ministre est
dans la ligne de mire et avec raison
à saint-paul dans le quartier où son
conjoint a grandi une murale avec les
visages de jeunes victimes des bavures
policières des visages devenue
tristement célèbre qu'on ne veut pas
oublier
[Applaudissements]
pendant longtemps dit elle les gens ne
croyaient pas que la police était
capable de tels gestes
il n'y a pas eu assez de changements
depuis la mort de john flou et dit
l'avocate et militante ni qui m'a dit
armstrong
la loi actuelle permet à la police de
tuer en toute impunité dit elle c'est la
structure même du système selon elle peu
importe les vidéos utilisé en preuve
c'est la couleur de la peau qui fait la
différence le lien de confiance entre la
police et la communauté afro américaine
semble quasi inexistant lors des émeutes
le poste de quartier où travaillait
derrick chauvin a littéralement été
incendiés
aujourd'hui l'immeuble ressemble à un
lieu désaffecté désormais ce sont des
caméras robot qui surveille ses
quartiers à quelques kilomètres de là la
pharmacie sud
eliane ou sow venait à peine de l'ouvrir
dans le quartier en septembre 2009 à
notre pharmacie a été détruite et pillée
dit il mais je comprends la colère des
gens je suis avec la famille de jauge
floride il a rouvert il ya six mois avec
l'aide des gens du quartier
nous avons besoin de la police dit il
mais les choses doivent changer
tout ceci n'est pas arriver du jour au
lendemain joue-t-il de série à cela
remonte à l' esclavage à la ségrégation
au racisme c'est ancré dans l'histoire
américaine c'est gravé dans le système
dit il est tout à ce stade et il doit
changer car le procès de derek chauvin
est un peu le procès de ce système et
c'est pour cette raison qu'ils sont
nombreux à manifester non loin de la
place georges floyd un cimetière
symbolique des victimes de la brutalité
policière
comme si elles étaient tombés au combat
des métiers en 1955 au mississippi à
jaws floyd en 2020 au minnesota avec ce
procès l'amérique est appelé à faire son
examen de conscience
si à sa bonne longueur guise radio
canada minneapolis